- I be making create-a-players
in Madden, I ain’t gonna lie,
and I be playin’ with them.
So, you know, their stats 99.
- I been doin’ that since I was a kid, man.
I would create my own players,
put 99 on everything, yeah.
- I been playin’ Madden since ‘99,
you feel me? So, like, hey, I love Madden.
- I ain't comin out the house cuz I'm on Madden.
- Hey, yo, this Swae.
- Yo, what up? This is Druski.
- This 42 Dugg
- Ay, yo, what's up? J.I.D.
- What's goin’ on? It's Morray.
- Tripstar, you already know.
- Hey y'all, this is Sally Sossa.
- This is Certified Speaker, Moneybagg Yo.
- What's up? This is BRS Kash.
- This is HaHa Davis right here with Bleacher Report.
- I'm gonna go through my personal
Madden ratings with you guys. Let's go.
I would rank my speed 9.8
cuz I'm really, like,
fast and like, really—
I got a lot of core strength.
- Probably a 99, man. High as it can go.
- I would rate my speed a...75.
- All right, speed, 0-99, I was gonna
say 99, but you led with somethin’ I ain’t got.
So I’ll say, just to be fair to myself,
I’ll give me a 50.
- [Laughing]
Gotta give me a solid 50.
I ain’t gonna burn off the line,
but if I catch it, it’s over.
- My knees be hurtin’ sometimes,
so, you know, I’d give myself a 75.
I ain’t gonna say I’m 100.
- A 99.
- Oh, I’m for sure a 99.
- My speed would be at least a 97.
When I was in my heyday,
my 40 was a consistent,
like, 4.4.
I could run that whole football
field right now in five seconds.
- It’s a lotta slims on Interscope, you feel me?
So they probably can run.
I ain't even
gonna rock with it.
They got me. They got me.
- My agility, man, I would have
to rank that
9.9 because I got a lotta
body control and core strength.
Like, I’d say that I have
core strength. So I could like—
if I want my body to go right,
you better believe we goin’
to the right.
If I'm gonna go
left, we goin’ to the left.
You know what I'm sayin’?
- Agility, I'd say a 60. I’ll
go 10 more than the speed.
You know, I can build that up.
But just off the speed, you know,
I’ll say 50. But agility, I’ll say 60.
- 99.
- 99 everything, man.
- Everything 99.
- My tackling ability would be at least a 92.
I used to hit legs cuz I was smaller than
everybody and I was super fast.
With my junior year, I had,
like, 55 tackles at corner.
That's really good for a cornerback
Made all-conference and all of that.
Like, you can't really beat that.
- I’m kinda slim-built.
I'm a slim-built guy. I don’t really
wanna be running my body
into other bodies and stuff.
I mean, I ain't saying
that I'm scared to do it.
Like, I’d get ‘em
on the ground, on the turf, but.
- Oh, that’s 99. My tackling ability,
I mean, that’s 99. I ain’t gonna lie to you.
When I played football,
if I hit you, you felt me. I promise
you. I promise you you felt me.
- Oh, my tackling ability, that’s 100.
You know, we get down.
I used to do that when we was
in high school.
- I wanna make sure I’m at full health.
You know what I'm sayin’?
So I can keep takin’ off,
you know what I'm sayin’?
Getting to the ball, you
know what I'm saying?
Get where I need to be, runnin’ the plays,
you know what I'm sayin’?
I don't wanna have no injuries
and be on the injury list, so
my tackling, I'm gonna say zero.
Cuz, like, I ain’t even on the defense.
Like, you feel me?
- My catching, my catching gonna be 100 too.
That’s easy.
- Oh, I got an 80. 85.
Yeah.
Slide and glide.
You feel me? Pick-six, you know
I’m catching it. Do you feel me?
- My catching ability is
like a 80 out of 100.
- Shit, whatever he throws, I’m
catching them motherfuckers.
Whatever he throws.
- My catching on Madden would be a 67.
[Laughing]
I really never been
able to catch like that.
- Oh, my overall football ability? Just
give me 99s all the way down the board.
99s.
I'mma just say 99.
Cuz I'm like, every—[laughing]
everywhere.
What else you want?
Like, I'm playin’ defense.
So I ain't really gotta
catch the ball like that.
You know what I'm sayin’?
I'm breaking up. I’m a kick returner.
You know what I'm sayin’? I’mma
make the tackles. I'mma just do my part.
That's all defense about.
- 94.
-  Definitely 99 on Madden. I ain’t lost all day.
- I'm gonna give myself a 50.
I'mma give myself a halfway.
- I’ll give me a solid 80.
Just cuz my awareness. My awareness is,
like, 1000.
It makes up for everything
I lack.
- I'mma say
100 out of 100 cuz
why not?
- 99, for sure. I feel like all of
us in the 99 Club, fo sho.
Make sure y’all check out my
new music in the Madden game.
- Listen, y’all go and get that Madden 22.
Out now.